euromaxx highlights and here's your host
cayenne hempstead greetings from berlin
and a warm welcome to our highlights
edition and we've got these and other
stories lined up for today's program
future food create your favorite dishes
with a 3d printer spot the Stars
gate-crashing at some major bashes at
the barely nala
and give him a hand photographer ray
Massey's optical illusion well the hype
was absolutely huge around the first 3d
printers when they emerged a few years
ago a manufacturing revolution was
underway and meanwhile with the price of
those printers becoming more and more
affordable the technique is being used
to make everything from shoes to lamps
to instruments well that inspired one
Spanish startup to take the idea even
further and they recently unveiled a 3d
printer to create food and not very
appetizing you might be thinking but we
went to see who's keen to use it and how
star chefs and twins xavier and sergio
torres described themselves as both
spanish and international they enjoy
experimenting in their restaurant above
the rooftops of Barcelona and that means
combining fresh homegrown produce with
modern technology their kitchen devices
are always state-of-the-art
de sergio is trying out a 3d food
printer he's currently printing rice
pudding and honeycomb form it's novel
for sure but it's too early to assess
the impact of these technological
innovations on the way we eat yo p no VA
que suena thermal to school and said
they offer a lot of opportunities but
we'll have to see try things out analyze
things the ingredients need a cookie
dough like consistency the mouse goes
into capsules and the printing can begin
the resulting shape still have to go
into the oven as do printed pizzas to
which toppings are added by hand the 3d
food printer which goes by the name
Houdini was developed by a Spanish
startup company Lynette kuzma is one of
the startups for founders it's easy to
think of it as an assembly device so
take ravioli is an example how often do
people make homemade ravioli from
scratch probably not very often despite
the plethora of pasta machines on the
market from a home-kitchen perspective
people are interested in making fresh or
foods whether it's whole meals or snacks
from a restaurant perspective they're
really interested in the design or
elements
the device will hit the market this year
it will retail for a thousand euros the
idea is that the chef programs the
design of the dish into the computer and
as this spinach tart shows the creative
possibilities are endless imagine you
went home tonight and you printed
something on fruity knee that you create
it and you want to share it with your
friends you can share through social
media sites upload your recipe to a
community and recommend to a friend that
hey you know I really came up with this
cool thing to print out Houdini I think
you should try it's really good it feels
like this has come out of a printer yeah
and it's edible it's good it can't be
from a printer it's really good it's
great the shapes are imaginative tasty
really tasty letter food tastes good but
only if those who are making it and
baking it know what they're doing mente
que llamas thankfully our hands will not
become obsolete the machine can't make
the food taste good it doesn't cook it
for you what it does help with is the
visuals and to create shapes that
wouldn't be possible without it y
seguramente a crea for mas que tu no
podria hacer otra manera
artichokes in iberian ham sauce is a
classic Spanish dish that's been newly
interpreted by the Torres brothers 3d
printer is a source of inspiration
extinct about this i turn the artichokes
upside down and draw something in the
artichoke itself or use the sauce to
draw the artichoke and then sit the
artichoke on top of it yeah lemos p.m.
prototype off I've already ordered a
prototype to practice on yeah y porque
si no so we have so many ideas about
what we could do with it demos probar la
stamos man we want to try them out and
see if they work see look up in samos
puede if they do would be amazing he is
crazy city among new people no sabemos
the brothers have already written their
restaurant logo using a puree from their
new menu so they're off to a great start
well all this past week the belly Nala
that's berlin international film
festival has been underway and it's an
event that gives this city's already
erudite shake an extra portion of glam
on the festival is not only a major
platform for the art of film but it's
also a gathering a key gathering of
industry professionals and so the list
of parties is pretty nearly endless but
what might look like carefree hobnobbing
is most often serious business the
valley nama turns Berlin into the city
that never sleeps after the film
premieres over that's when the party's
really get going
from casting directors to actors to
directors it's a who's who of cinema the
name of the game is to see and be seen
reviews and mix though
poppies and insets parties are awful
horrible so superficial everyone's lying
and saying oh you look wonderful I hate
parties that's why I'm always going to
them it's nice that everyone is involved
in the same event for the same reasons
like everyone here loves film and and
and is talking about film which is great
and boxer it's a fun way to meet up and
talk to people otherwise you just see
the same people every day come on his
mere remark the festival keeps getting
better and it's so central dancing Scott
get this money feel about you meet the
filmmakers here and the funders that's
how films are made that's why it's
important to be here CBC kids as I know
no one no sir the heart of the festival
is here at potsdamer platz a major film
sponsor is holding a reception at the
ritz-carlton it's invitation only no
autograph seekers allowed screenwriter
honored Lieberman has one of the coveted
invites it's a special Berlin Allah for
her this year she has a movie in the
main competition program and is vying
for a Golden Bear
this time under Fela it's great to have
the feeling yes I'm legit I can walk
around and have my picture taken other
times I felt a bit like an impostor this
time I feel like yes I'm allowed to be
here with my dress and lipstick bag ones
are all soon she spent the morning
rushing from one appointment to the next
the veteran actress and screenwriter
lives in Berlin so she's a pro when it
comes to the festival it's good i'll get
that suit interview story part of our
job is giving lots of entities feel it
into the story then you have sponsors
who hold receptions where you also have
to make an appearance will you get an
invitation to something and for us
ladies part of our job is looking nice
too I'm an octet saw dancing agosto zoom
Pokemon is helping promote her film
Stations of the Cross with her
appearances so even after hours events a
part of her job description since we
cannot under arts it's a different kind
of party because you always have it in
the back of your mind that you're not
just part here you're there to see and
be seen and it's like a big family event
is from years it can get pretty crazy
isn't just a quite a sterile sure
about 20,000 industry pros have gathered
for the ten-day festival and that means
galas and receptions galore across the
entire city a major tarbush and
broadcaster is hosting a bash at the
museum for communication for the actors
and filmmakers here it's a way to
express their gratitude and that means
celebrating to the flash of the cameras
and in view of their sponsors it's more
like work than a party to see aha
weights understand its work but it's
also fun where else can you have a glass
of wine when you're working fine thing
for me studies much it's a chance to see
people in the industry voice and to see
friends some of whom I haven't seen in
ages ABC kazie nobbut like me maybe I'll
see a producer who will offer me a role
no no that's not why I'm here I just
want to be part of it Fiona cute easter
bites design leave odd yeah it's my job
and that's why I'm here popular this
year thank the Lord I don't have a film
here so I can just enjoy myself back to
Emma burgerman he's off to the
after-party accompanied by her film team
her family and friends
it's packed but she manages to catch up
with a few friends there got to talk
about and Antigua van it was a crazy day
I was pretty wrecked after the premiere
and now I'm glad my friends are here
yeah but I'll go home soon I have to
catch a cab at 8am tomorrow for the next
interview whether it's a premier gala or
a celebrity reception at the Berlin
Allen the stars certainly come out at
night
well parties and schmoozing with the
glitterati are certainly the last thing
on Sylvia foot banglas mind five years
ago she and her family emigrated from
Germany to rural Norway where she now
concentrates on her main passion which
is dog sled racing third finger is in
fact one of the world's top mushers and
one of very few women in that field and
she's the owner of 37 Huskies who amount
to much more than just best friends
ziglia fort wrangler always prepares the
sled out of sight of her dogs they're so
eager that it's easier to wait till
she's ready to leave then she heads off
with her team of 13 through the
wilderness of Norway after 30 kilometres
Sylvia's Alaskan Huskies are still going
strong the sled dogs are known for their
endurance and they continue running into
the night
it takes the dogs a little while to
settle down after their workout but then
they're ready for dinner today there's
only dry dog food on the menu here in
the south of Norway at the next town
that has a butcher of where she can get
fresh meat is more than 40 kilometers
away I am devil is one of her favorites
as I'm not endeavor if it's he's not a
devil at all he doesn't live up to his
name he's a complete sweetheart Gabe the
dogs give so much back to me and I'm
really grateful they're what makes the
dream possible the dream of sledding the
adventure and the expedition's as well
as making it possible for us to take
part in big races XP on Monday after Sun
courses and one tiny enough Julia and
her dog teams have been taking part in
the world's top races for years now last
year they competed in the grande ought
to say in the French Alps there was a
blizzard overnight it snowed so much
that some of the dog camels were buried
under the snow sometimes Sylvia had to
get up in the middle of the night to
make sure that none of the dogs had been
trapped the muslin I'm not frozen to
cookie the sign hunting I wonder it is
we still it off I deploy that's the
first one the Huskies don't seem to care
all that much about their kennels
they're used to snow and cold
although it's just 210 kilometers away
from the capital of Oslo it's like
another world up here in the haedong
gravida national park there isn't even a
road leading up to the house on the
plateau
five years ago the fruit Wranglers moved
here with their Alaskan Huskies they
chopped their own wood for the stove
that heats the house and they make their
own bread they moved here in part
because of the sled dogs but they like
their simple life here to 18 year-old
steven gets up at five o'clock to go to
school it takes him an hour and a half
on the snowmobile to get to the town of
ryokan mean you know how's it going to
get on that dude
but the long distances are no problem
for Huskies if they could they'd run all
the way to review Khan themselves
because of the blizzard they're stuck
here for three days when zilvia finally
gets the sled out and her husband Jurgen
prepares the harnesses the dogs are
beside themselves with excitement the
team will include 13 dogs again today
the older dogs have to stay behind and
so do the youngest ones like five month
old devil he'll have to wait until he's
about 18 months old to go on a training
run then it will take another three to
four years before he can be a lead dog
the team is raring to go every dog has
its own job the lead dog has the most
difficult job that's lion who has to
find the right path and respond to the
mushers commands in the back its
strength that counts most the strong
dogs that are placed directly in front
of the slider called wheelers it's their
job to pull the sled out of trenches in
the snow and around corners and trees
and they're off the Huskies come alive
with power and energy even though it's
starting to snow again zilvia
furtwängler is glad to be out again
training with her dog team
when it comes to painting or drawing or
sculpting you could say that hands are
the ultimate tools of the artist but in
the case of British photographer Ray
Massey hands are also his favorite
subject with the help of a body painter
colleague Massey creates to play
illusions using human hands as his
actual canvas and so we went to see the
process behind these astonishing shots
you only get these pictures when you
take a closer look the well camouflaged
hands transformed into art the pictures
were taken by the renowned British
photographer Ray Massey I became a
photographer because I didn't want a
desk job I think was the main incentive
but now I discovered photography when I
was about 13 we did pinhole camera in
general science at school and when I saw
my first print sort of come up in the
developer that was you know just totally
fine that was absolutely magical today
messy is recreating the screen by
Norwegian painter Edward monk the hand
model Tara Malik this is an unusual kind
of shoot sometimes you have hand molds
we've got fantastic hands but somehow
they don't really understand quite what
to do with them and headbutt invitar is
really really patient and you know
understanding what we're trying to
achieve
ray Massey's longtime collaborator is
British artist Andy rally she helps him
create his optical illusions it takes
her hours to prepare the models hands
today she spent three hours with Tara
says contours on land and it's going in
and it's slightly distorted I have to
look at it from the angle of the camera
and then paint it accordingly the shoot
is taking place and Ray Massey studio
housed in a former Church in the North
London borough of Camden it was here in
the capital that his career began back
in the swinging 60s this is where he
studied and worked as an assistant to
some famous photographers including
Richard avidin I really wasn't enchanted
with the fashion world a studio full of
egos of art directors of fashion editors
of hair stylist makeup art it was my
idea of hell he seemed found his neat
still life he's been working in
advertising as a photographer for four
decades now he made a name for himself
first and foremost with what's called
liquid photography he started taking his
hand photographs after he created some
images for an ad campaign for a British
insurance company they were picked up
and reproduced in the media and numerous
blogs it prompted Ray Massey to see what
else he could do with hand photography
we're trying to produce an emotion with
with the hands and if we talk to the
person you can always make a person look
happy or sad or smile grumpy screw up
your eyes you know whatever you can be
rude to them and make them arrogant you
could control things but it's much
harder to get some kind of feeling or
story into the hands isn't it and I say
I hand sometimes you can move them one
millimeter and they go from looking
beautiful to be very ugly because
they're not really intrinsically pretty
things so the next time you're in London
don't put your hands in your pockets you
never know you might just be discovered
by Ray Massey
and we finish off with a trip to a
beautiful to roll that's a state in
western Austria that's made up almost
entirely of mountains which means of
course that it's extremely popular with
outdoor enthusiasts both in the summer
and the winter and kits booth is one of
its best-known resorts well in fact the
ski areas in and around the torn pass in
the kitzbühel alps were recently named
the best in the country and so we went
to see what all awaits the lucky visitor
between the three thousand meter high
peaks of the kitzbühel alps the only way
is down but what makes this area between
cashback and yock Berg one of the
largest ski areas in Europe is the 3.5
kilometer cable car that bridges an
entire valley every day winter sports
enthusiasts can explore new territory
here more than 170 kilometres of slopes
tempt skiers to ride to the top there's
something for everyone
we should i love them out yes what could
be better if you experience the
mountains like this you want to come
here again and again okay yeah I might
give up you come here and see this if
you're here with heart and soul it's
just fantastic I'm [ __ ] with call moft
Assad fleet has a lot of atmosphere and
Claire the slopes are well prepared
quite over yet and even away from the
slopes there's a lot on offer in the
zone Boot Hill a for example you can
recharge your batteries for the next ski
run in rustic surroundings when booking
skiing lessons at the red devil ski
school a visit to the best Chile's is
included in the price and the Red Devils
can teach you the perfect skiing
techniques from simple terms for
beginners to race training ya mouth not
before there's the snowplow turn for
beginners and beyond that anything is
possible these are that's awful comfy
mafia always depends on the guests and
what shape they're in since then the
small town of kits pool has developed
into a meeting place for the rich and
famous no wonder that the old town has
become a glamorous shopper's paradise
the first address in style is France
Pradas boutique for more than 50 years
he has produced tailor-made skiing and
winter fashion for kids Burroughs guests
from all over the world
my nails my first celebrity customer was
Romy Schneider who learned to ski here
back then stirrup pants with a fashion
we made a lot for her hands glaziers
everything romy schneider came here
often but I lets me have a few come out
the aroma Schneider boss a fig premier
tailored ski pants was something act as
Robert Redford and Roger Moore also
appreciated the celebrities who shopped
it France prada usually stayed at the
hotel lieutenant it's been the epitome
of terally in hospitality for nearly 100
years she'll a woman and a lot of
celebrities who come here like the fact
that we don't make a fuss over film gang
with Medina though Tyrol ians are very
passionate people that and that can be
seen in the way they deal with guests
compo inside him steal k mu buggiest
showing up deliver and those who answer
keen on the hustle and bustle of
kitzbühel apres ski can retreat to the
kids blue valley where the quiet village
of yogurt hides a culinary secret
thus our cars are steuben serves
thoroughly in cuisines such as soup with
chopped tripe and fresh bread
and whoever is willing to travel 1200
meters up the slope dough ball z is on
bag storm will be warmly greeted by its
guitar playing owner duction food I need
the gospel if I met synthesis of course
the guests must feel that you like them
and that they're welcome coming i always
say i love my guests and people probably
notice that everything comes from the
heart that there's nothing fake about it
that's what islam helps i enjoy doing
this and i also like to sing from
renovating again singing always brings
people together in 15 de uma at jose's
on and back Steuben the celebrations
often go late into the night showing it
to all can be a whole lot of fun too
that's all we have time for today so
thanks very much for watching and if you
want to know any more about any of those
reports just head to our website or be
sure to catch up with us on facebook but
for now unless go to vons here in Berlin
or Joffe doesn't
you